from those things are establish the
pray
it and Subhan Allah look at the
wisdom uh of our religion and look how
the messenger Sall alai wasam was
blessed
with with with words that were short but
vast in meaning as the shik has
emphasized the prophet sallu alaihi
wasallam could have mentioned to pray to
S but when it mentions
to it has a much more broader meaning
and these are the meanings that are
derived from that from these meanings
is for the men that they should offer
these prayers these five daily prayers
that are the obligated prayers is that
they should offer them in congregation
in the
Masid it is an
obligation upon the
men every man that has the ab
ability to go to the Masjid and to pray
with congregation then he should do so
and it's an obligation for him the
messenger
sallam he said in
theith whoever hears the call and
referring to
the so the messenger sallallah alai
wasallam says whoever hears the aan the
call to prayer and he does not answer
not answer meaning he does not go to the
Masjid this is what answering means
answering the call of
the the intent here is that he does not
answer meaning that he did not go to the
Masid to pray in
congregation then there is no prayer for
him no prayer for him meaning it well we
will talk about that
shortly then there is no prayer for
him except for the one that has an
excuse except for the one that has an
excuse so the she before I go into
detail regarding that Hadith I'm going
to give you some cam
of it's not from in the book ofan but
it's it's appropriate that I mention it
however then he
says valid question if every person will
pray in their own residence or in their
workplace or wherever they may be then
what was the reason for thean to be
legislated if everyone can just pray in
their homes if everyone meaning the men
if the men could pray at their homes or
pray in their workplaces wherever it
will be then what was the need of the to
be
legislated indeed the when the
mentions come to the
prayer come to that which gives you
success which
means mean come and pray with the
congregation
in the houses of the mighty and
Majestic except for the one that has a
uh reason or is
excused and what is
the what is the they have they have
said commonly known
is some fear oh oh sickness these are
from the that are
mentioned
however and also the Shi
says then sh himself mentioned some
extra he says for example a person lives
in a place where there is no
congregation there is no Masid
there is no place of a Masid or
congregation for then this person prays
wherever he
is but
question in this
country we do not hear the
aan and
many of theith mention even regarding
the blind man that came to the Messenger
s Al wasallam and he did not have anyone
that could take him and assist him to go
to the Masjid so the Messenger s alai
wasallam sorry he questioned the
messenger Al wasam that do I is it
permissible for me to pray at home so
then the messenger Sall alai wasam said
to
him do you hear the call then he said
yes then the messenger Al wasallam
commanded him to answer to the call
so and in this Hadith that we have here
regarding if you hear the
call in this country we do not hear the
call of aan does that mean that the
people that live in the west where they
do not hear the aan it is not obligated
for them to pray in the mass because
they have not heard the
call hey
what do you
say
h the Hadith clearly says if you hear
the call answer it meaning the aan so
it's made from
there the use that is obligatory for you
to pray in the Masid in congregation but
the question is if we don't hear that
call if you don't hear that call then do
you have is it oblig is it an obligation
for you to pray in the mass in the west
hey
well so you're saying that if you live
within a distance which is close to the
Masjid then you should but if you live
far you don't have
to and you agree with him
a are you answering a question or you
are asking me a question no no I I need
answers from you guys before I give you
the answer
was asked this
question
and he
says he said that the focal point is not
that you actually hear thean that you
have and
awareness of the
time of the prayer the time of the
prayer that you are aware if you have
ilm and knowledge that this prayer is at
this time then this is the intent so
it's obligated then he gave the example
he said even if you're in an Islamic
country say you in Islamic Country and
and you
work in a in a factory
methan and the factory is next to a
Masid but when you are in the
factory due to the heavy machines the
loud machines that are working away the
aan is being made but you in this
Factory that is next to the Masjid but
you can't hear the aan would it be
correct to say that we didn't hear the N
so it's not obligated for us to pray in
the Masjid even if you're in a Muslim
land the sh was
saying it happens sometimes that you
could be so close to a Masid but due to
your work you may not you you're
drilling heavy if you're a builder you
may not hear the aan even in an Islamic
land this is so would it be correct then
to say that the person next to the Masid
due to him not hearing the aan does not
have to attend the
congregation what would you
say he should attend even
though even though he didn't hear the
aan so this is the the point that the
shik is making the shik is making the
point that even if you are living in the
west if you are aware that the Salah is
at this time if you are aware that in
that Masjid they established such and
such prayer at such and such time then
you should
attend then we also have another
Mah and the shik he says here Alan this
is he
says as for the one that is close to the
Masid he he the
he is healthy and he is
safe then there is no prayer for him for
the one that prays in his home if he is
thean and going back to the Hadith this
Hadith uh whomsoever hears the
call and he does not answer
there is no prayer for him what is the
intent and the
meaning that there is no prayer for him
what does it mean meaning that his Salah
is null and void what does it mean
likewise was asked this question
regarding this had
first first Alani was asked regarding
the authenticity of this Hadith and he
said sah this
Hadith which is mentioned in Ma and
likewise mentions in
and the
is said it is
authentic then the shik was asked
regarding
what is its
intent there is no prayer for
him he
said as for his Salah
being meaning not
accepted it is not accepted if he prayed
at home and you heard thean first you
have to understand the Mas before I tell
you so what is the Mas we talking about
now you hear the Alan and you pray at
home and the wording of the Hadith
is there is no prayer for him what does
that mean this is what we're talking
about now what does that mean there is
no prayer for him so the shikh was asked
does it mean that is b b meaning not
accepted it's not
accepted the shik answered by saying
that statement to say that the Salah is
not accepted is the statement of
Islam Islam was the one that
says with the one that doesn't have an
excuse
however he
says this uh statement of the Salah not
being accepted oppos is the majority of
the
scholars so then how do we understand it
so the negation of the Hadith that it's
not
accepted the meaning of that
is rather it negates that it is complete
in Excellency and in reward and it does
not negate that the Salah is not correct
it doesn't mean that the Salah is not
correct but rather it means
you that you will not gain the full
reward because if you pray in
congregation then you get 27 times the
reward so what it means is that he will
not receive that reward but the Salah is
correct even if he prayed at home
um uses the following Hadith as a proof
to show you that the Salah is accepted
the Hadith of Abdullah
uses the following that the Messenger s
said that the prayer offered in
congregation is more superior to the
prayer that is prayed on his own by
27 uh times or 27
levels how is that a
proof how is that a proof how is Alani
using this Hadith to show that the one
that prays at home prayer is
correct because in the Hadith the
Messenger s alai wasallam says that the
one that prays in
congregation that prayer is 27 times
more virtuous if you was to pray alone
if you was to pray alone the messenger
wasallam mentioned praying alone and
didn't make inar of it so that was what
Al from his F uses this Hadith to show
you that if you pray alone and how we
understand that is deficient in reward
but the actual prayer is
correct that's just
of to let you know of
the Whoever has the ability then should
pray in congregation